like it was like Running of the Bulls
over there and diploma spaniel if you
guys have ever been no been there but um
every year in diploma they have a
Running of the Bulls and basically they
take the baddest Bulls in the world man
I'm talking a bunch of damn horse grunts
you feel me I'm talking abunch of
Scottie trip ins bruh and they let those
[ __ ] and loose through the city and
people have been drinking wine and
talking [ __ ] and people are wearing
t-shirts that say like you know go
Pistons or something or Celtics and for
you know and then these bad bets just
come through the street and like 7:00
a.m. because I've been there you know
I'm not bragging but I'm you know I
guess I'm boasting a little and then
that I mean you're out there and and uh
and they got wine and everybody people
drinking wine out of all kind of [ __ ]
you'll see a dude uh you'll see a dude
with a with a casket or whatever of wine
a flask it you'll see a dude with a
basket of wine a mask it you'll see a
dude wearing a mask he'll take that
[ __ ] off drink right out of it you like
down a dude's fricken huh it's the
Phantom of the slopper I do cuz that
dudes getting sloppy as hell off his
damn face piece um yeah yeah yeah you
see it all you know and then when
everybody's just liquored to the gills I
mean I mean your buddies just turned
into a damn largemouth bass but you are
liquored to the gills when you've had as
much wine as you can and people drinking
out of everything you'll see a dude
he'll he'll of he'll of uh installed a
damn tube in his um that's a fog as a
bra you know or whatever it's called
that you know that liquid pipe it takes
liquid into your body from your face
he'll have a tube installed in his s of
fog as Brun have that [ __ ] run right
back up to his mouth he's stepping out
of himself like us just a straw so he'll
drink some a little bit of that vino and
then just swallow it and then then
revisit that [ __ ] just he just recycling
that liquor right out of himself just
redoing it you know and you're all good
man you're out there and everybody's got
on white and red and everybody's got on
red and white and and then you think
it's fine you start to forget even that
it's a party cuz it's 7:00 a.m. those
Bulls they get up early for for work you
know cuz a bull doesn't have a really a
busy day really they got to be pissed as
hell and it's sometimes they use them
for sex but that's it otherwise they're
chillin man eatin corn eating grass
eatin I don't know some of them look
like they're on damn steroids if you
ever seen a bully like Danny I'm dude
like I must own a couple anytime
Fitness's you know because as I do been
eatin Halloween because that little
bastard is jack-o'-lantern bruh so then
you're out there in the street you're
out there in the street boy you forget
you forget it's a party
you're starting to check out some cheeks
you know some chick cos some chick got
us I would I don't even what they call
them Italian cheeks brah you know some
real legit euro ladies and they're
flirting and people are starting dancing
you know Oh papa
oh you're no papa yo no Papa no Nino's
for me you know and you think
everything's cool you forget bruh cause
you've been drinking and then about a
dozen of the angriest animals you ever
singing come run it through bruh and
first all the chicks disappear all the
women that are they are disappearing
like oh man what happened you know
that Larry's dad come home or something
because we saw a way do we all got the
party's over you know did rot you know
did Ronnie's grandfather find out or
something that we're out here in the
boathouse because we're [ __ ] you know
what happened
did somebody spray mace or something at
the party because all the chicks start
leaving the climbing over the fence
isn't climbing over they got these big
like twelve by twelve s really they
really are they put them all along the
streets the street ways and it's
beautiful streets cobblestone and then
you hear the bottom about a biodome
you're like damn somebody's trying to
move a piano or something you know
because you forget cuz you've been
drinking ya been right and then if you
see one bull go by you like that ain't a
thing who somebody better come catch
that bastard and then you see eleven
more yeah and they keep ripping through
and it's just it's magical if you never
been there go watching and go see but
here's what happens is at the end they
the fighters there's a swordsman there's
a swordsman a guy out there really
really it's almost like a larper like
one of those guys you see in the park
like if they got a real nerd he's out
there in the park or something you know
it's like some guy who basically the guy
that won the Renaissance Fair in America
they take him to Italy and give him a
damn battalion or something you know uh
like a sword man you know that blood
peace baby that sword and that dude pops
off with it he starts fighting the bulls
and uh and oh wait here's up first he
has a carpet and the Bulls come by and
he showed him the carpet and they don't
every time they don't want to buy it
they just run right through they don't
even even buying that [ __ ] you know and
he only got one carpet it's kind of like
a rerun a little it's like oh you want
to buy it
it's like not a run right by Queen and
we don't want it and he'll shake that
bastard out there again you know just
like he's beating his car mats off over
about a car wash by the DIY carwash so
why not like to use and he's just you
know like he's shaking out the floor
mats of a damn 84 Ford Escort and uh and
then eventually the bull gets so tired
and he swords a mountain and he swords
him out and they drag it off they drag
the bull off at the end and uh uh I mean
there was some moral to this story that
really was there was a moral to the
story but you know how it is man and you
know how it ain't good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one